[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers
my friends this is gunjan here welcome
to my 52nd episode
of chess trap series in today's lecture
we are going to see a beautiful counter
trap
in the pattern of defense from the black
perspective
the opening arises after the following
mortar
e4 e5 knight to f3
and now rather than defending the pawn
black plays
this counter-attacking move knight to f6
asking question to wide which part
you are going to choose
now recently due to the increase of
popularity
in the stafford gambit which can arises
after knight captures e5 and the move
knight to c3
white player choose the second big
alternative
namely d4 known as
modern attack
well if you have petrov or the stafford
gambit
in your rapurta then you really don't
want to miss out
this opening trap as after
the main line knight captures e4 white
has
two major choices one is
bishop to d3 however by far
the most popular choice is d captures e5
which is in fact played by many white
player
and the intention is very clear
he has set up an opening trap
so if you see this position first time
most likely
any black player will churn out this
move
bishop to c5 which looks very obvious
saying white hey you did something wrong
in the opening
and now i am attacking on the f2 square
white really do not want to play bishop
to e3 in this positions
because after simple bishop captures e3
and pawn captures e3
white get horrible double e pawn
which can leads to disaster so nope
that's not a big idea what really
white has set up is he wants to play
queen to d5 and as you can see the cruel
intention
white is simply threatening a piece
okay now the black response is forced
he has to take on f2 and
if white has come this far then he has
to play king to e2
because if he continue with king to d1
then there is no pressure on this bishop
so black can simply defend his knight
with f5 and after some obvious
continuation
e captures f6 knight captures f6
queen to e5 check queen to e7
and wants the queen's exchange the net
result is
both the king are misplaced but
black is a clear pawn up
so king to e2 what else
white insists that now i'm really
attacking two of your pieces
and there is no way for black to escape
from this deadly trap
and yes indeed at far side it looks like
black is really in the trouble except
the matter of fact is it is black
who has set up a counter trap here
so before i move on guys i like you to
pause this video and find out
a cunning sequence where actually
black can come out on top in each of the
line
are you ready let's get start
the first move is very obvious
f5 defending the knight as well as the
bishop on f2
and now in order to eject that e4 knight
white has two options number one
if we continue with knight to c3 then i
think
this is even worse because
after c6 attacking the queen
queen to d3 and now the star move
queen to e7 gives black a completely
opening advantage the point is
after knight captures e4 pawn captures
e4
and queen captures e4 yes time being our
bishop is hanging
but look at the initiative black is
getting
d5 attacking the queen queen to d3
and now when simply black retrieved the
bishop
back to b6 if you carefully look at this
position
yup material is equal but
as far as the most important phase of
the game
king safety white has severely
compromised his king where black is
just one move away from the castling
so in a nutshell knight c3 is a bad idea
by the white camp
well many of you will say but hang on
isn't white can simply take on appsx
deflecting the e4 knight so that
after knight captures f6 yes for a time
being
black knight is attacking queen but once
white gives this check isn't he is going
to
win a piece
well sometimes chess give you those
illusions
but after black's next reply that is
king to f7 suddenly
white to his horror find out that
not only he is upon down but
the whole concept to naboo peace
completely fails here
as king to f2
leads to simple knight to g4
and suddenly white sweetie is a
corner so after king to f7
probably the best response here is
knight to g5
but even though this leads to a position
where black is
completely winning and i'm going to show
you a sample line
king to g8 still white cannot take our
bishop
and we are all set to kick this white
knight
with the move at 6. and funny enough
if you put this position in any chess
engine
it clearly says that white has some huge
problem the best move suggested here
is knight to e4 but i don't think so
even after this
white can save his cave i propose this
simple sequence
bishop to b6 knight captures f6
jack queen to f6
queen to ea check and now you simply
block the path so that if
white exchanged the queen then the net
result is
once again same yup
both the king are misplaced but quite
emerge
with a clear pawn advantage in the end
game
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile counter trap in the pattern
of defense
remember if you open and place queen to
d5
thinking that he is going to win a piece
well give him this root shock with
bishop captures f2
and as i have shown in this video after
this
no matter however white wriggles
black's opening advantage cannot be
denied thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care